une étude révèle que deux femmes sur
trois ne supporte pas leur apparence en
photo moi je supporte pas ah bon en
apparence en photo mais vous vous prenez
en photo en vous embrassant les biceps
savoir c'est pour faire plaisir aux
autres
alors ici je voulais et c'est pareil
pour garder ça c'est fou non mais c'est
vrai qu'ils aiment bien se voir en photo
un et en peinture à jamais la mémoire de
dos ah ouais je rejoins pensant que ça
vous gêne
t on trop tôt pour juliette à la
recherche de la pause l'angle et la
lumière parfaite faut souvent 50 prise
73 part j'habite peut-être mais en
général on n'est pas tout de suite
satisfaite mais je pense que c'est le
fait que sur instagram sur les réseaux
tout soit embellie qui soit parfait j'ai
surtout des retours au niveau de la
photo d'identité femme elle se trouve
toujours un peu plus vieilli je suis pas
bien tandis que c'est vrai que chez un
homme généralement tout va toujours bien
et ce complexe chez les femmes augmenter
avec l'âge le temps passe et ben on se
rend compte que voilà on a pris quelques
rides ou ont vieilli fin en voilà le
visage forcément change
l'amour fait que les rites disparaissent
et on ne regarde l'autre c'est pas de
moi oui le feu la
jolie non mais vous vous aimez ou en
photo pas du tout j'aime pas du tout
sinon des photos très complexée par mes
oreilles coupées
dans les celi voulons absolument je
cache mon oreille est petit on
m'appelait l'éléphant là comme ça si on
m'appelait pour l'éléphant lui pour
d'autres non et
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui laissez vous aller vers v
twin villages
ou des
fromages et desserts au
kéké complète c'est pas rigolo daniel
pourquoi t'as pas les châteaux banon
mais toi alors mais je crois que tu en
fais toi tu es en train de faire un déni
les esprits non mais sans déconner c'est
vrai tu fais un déni de ta beauté les
bassins lui dit tu es belle je t'aime et
toi moi je
moi je
ce livre donne un peu confiance je te
dis ah mais oui j'ai toujours voté en
fait tu étais dans le choix pendant des
années non mais je te jure qu'elle est
magnifique mais c'est le regard de
l'autre qui vous pas une fois qu'on se
sente désirs et ses fils et moi j'la
ghazi
pas là maintenant mais bon c'est la
coupe de nicolas savoye ce
qu'apparemment s'il me fait la coupe de
nicolas parce qu apparemment
tout le monde
non mais c'était vraiment c'est dans son
look ça non mais c'est vrai ces six
états à vous vous êtes très belle comme
ça vous ne plaisait comme ça non
d'amendés complexé depuis mais toujours
depuis toujours la même ben franchement
on n'est elle pas agnel il faut que tu
reprennent confiance en cuir montella
était vraiment une belle femme et je
charrie main
j'ai pas dit a dit ça qui t'a fait
croire ça pendant ta vision pleurais je
te jure que tu es magnifique puis je
[Applaudissements]
n'est pas
réglé mais oui mais moi mais moi je
serais tombé que moi je te galoche rep
qu'un soir je vais commencer
[Rires]
je n'ai jamais on ne mettons pas la
charrue avant les boeufs cyril est ce qu
on peut juste lancé un hashtag tout
simplement oui on t'aime daniel pour les
gens disent a dit la dernière can et
mondial et je te le jour et tu que je
pense vraiment c'est pas mal je te
promets à côté de la gare elle servait
wiki le contraire de moi moi je suis
dégueulasse je mal avec ça
[Rires]
tu peux montrer n'importe quel jour
alors qu'on était très vexé on est comme
on est le monde 8 avec comme ça c'est
une raison donc il faut taxer pts et
aimer et allez hop un juste toi non non
j'ai pas sûr que tu dois porter bonheur
à ce maintien t'occupe pas que ça
occupe sa timidité
du lilas nous cassent panique
je te dis que tu es magnifique boîte toi
c'est juste une question de confiance
sont pas les siens mais j'ai toujours
été vrai qu'avant tout est
vraiment différent mais là c'est
vraiment bien sa grâce à une fois
qu'elle avait l'autre couple s'est dit
oui
mais c'était 200 jours et faire ma mère
est en demande elle était encore plus
maintenant tu veux que ton monde soit
blonde america mais les américains ils
veulent tous qu'on soit stéréotypé quoi
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] moi voilà je veux
être pas
de faire le beau dans le massachusetts
nord est ce cas-là ce qu'elle s'oublie
pas ça tu t'oublies
sur elle
jeudi
sur l
oubli sur sa durée c'est l'arrêt d'avoir
glissé dessus
et elle sait dénigre tout
moi tu vas venir avec moi cet été
pionnier une semaine avec soyaux une
semaine à coup c'est sur le yacht que
ça va venir manger des yaourts
à venir une semaine avec moi ouais pas
trois jours
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]